take 15 to 20 minutes off each day the
norm is not knowing what to do when
you're given the opportunity of 15 or 20
minutes right let me do a guided
meditation let me let me do some breath
work
let me take a walk
let me do these things that I can use to
get back in touch with me it's about
like finding one thing that will work
for you and then developing a way to
make that sustainable in your life
because it's the it's the consistency or
the repetition of the individual thing
it almost doesn't matter which of these
modalities you opt for as long as you
create a routine around them that works
within the construct of your life so
that you are actually doing it